The praying mantis appears to be such a zen
and calm creature.
After all, the prayer is directly in it’s
name!
But the praying is understandable considering
any sexual encounter for the male mantis,
might be fatal.
Praying mantis’ are characterized by the
unique and specialized behavior of sexual
cannibalism.
The sperm transfer process can be quite lengthy,
so this means that it’s important for a
male to occupy his female partner's’ attention
for as long as possible.
More time equals more of his own sperm making
its way into her reproductive tract AND less
time for other males to have a similar chance.
And one good strategy to maximize his monopoly
on a female's’ time is by letting her reach
back, rip off his head, and begin to consume
it.
Although in some cases a male might try to
escape, this may not be in his best biological
interest.
You see, while she is enjoying her appetizer,
his body continues to rhythmically pump sperm
into her body.
Once she’s done eating the head, she will
begin to consume the rest of his body, and
all the while his sperm continues to perform
the only task that matters to his future biological
existence.
By the time a female has finished consuming
the male, there is a very good chance that
a significant amount of his sperm is alive
and well in her sperm storage organ, and will
be used to sire the next generation.
Although it seems a rather severe way to attain
biological fitness, it makes sense seeing
as many of these males will only ever get
a few chances at copulation during their lifetimes.
Despite the fact that it’s a strategy unlike
anything close to what humans would encounter,
it seems to work well for several species
of mantis across the world.
I’m sure their future offspring would thank
them for taking one for the team.
For more videos about animals that aren’t
made out of paper, check out this playlist
from our friends at the Dodo.
Don’t forget to subscribe, and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos.